My name is Salma and I am a student.
I study with a lot of non-Muslim friends
and I'm so happy today I got the exact
answers that they usually ask me.
>> Sorry sister, I cannot. Can you put the
microphone on top please? Can the
volunteer help? Mashallah. Ladies are
very
Yes. Can you speak close to the
microphone slowly and clearly? My name
is Salma.
>> Yes, I got your name. Salma.
>> I am a student.
>> Yes. Yes, sir.
>> I study with a lot of non-Muslim
students.
>> Yes.
>> And I am happy today I have all the qu
answers to the questions that they ask
me.
>> Mashallah.
>> But I have two major questions on their
behalf.
>> Yes. The first one, if God gave me
wealth,
why do I have to give back to the
society as saddaka or zakat?
>> The sisters asked a question that she
has made our Muslim friends. But there
are two question which she could not
answer. One is that if I've got wealth,
why should I give it back to society as
satka? Because we believe that all the
wealth in the world belongs to Allah. So
if you have wealth, it actually belongs
to Allah. So Allah is testing you
whether you follow the commandment or
not. So Allah is just telling you I gave
you wealth now give 2.5%
of that saving not earning whatever
savings you have got whatever extra
wealth you have got more than the nisab
level more than 85 g of gold you should
give 2.5% of that in charity it is like
a father giving his son a million dollar
and then saying from that million dollar
give $25,000 in charity give it back to
me should the son give or not
>> he should give
>> who does it belong to father father is
testing
like is the son is he so greedy about
money I'm giving him so much asking him
to give 2.5% back to me or give in
charity so same way Allah all this
wealth belongs to Allah Allah is testing
you whether you are charitable or not
because one of the pillars in Islam is
zakat that is whatever extra saving you
have got give 2.5% charity ity. So if
you don't follow the commandment of
Allah, you fail the test. Hope that
answers the question.